[Musique]
j'ai vraiment partis vers la ville est
élevé par deux avec le bungalow de ce
pays dans un quartier de la classe
moyenne le show félix moreno l'est rêve
de devenir agriculteur
pendant ses études alité à avec l'aide
financière de ses parents il achète une
terre et des animaux d'élevage pour la
viande
alors âgé de 23 ans il se retrouve ici
seuls à saint-boniface de shawingan 18
vaches en 2009 pas nettoyeur à baroin on
voulait on était jeune et con pour
arriver ils occupent un emploi à
l'extérieur mais travailler seul à la
ferme ça devient lourd
peut-être ne l'avouent ils finissent par
sympathiser avec son ancien maître de
stage et voisins de terre un producteur
de lait je travaillais depuis ma cape
town un peu plus ici avec sa ferme même
en captant un peu mais quand c'est
disons voici de courir ensemble pour
arriver à marcher c'est ainsi qu'il ya
quatre ans jean félix a vendu ces
animaux de boucherie écrit avec françois
une nouvelle ferme
[Musique]
jean-félix devient producteur de lait
juste pour entrer dans ce type de
production contingenté avec peu de boyer
c'est un tour de force car on s'est
associés on a amené les deux actifs aps
les deux passive dans l'entreprise qu'on
a dit c'est comme ça qu'on a pu les
faire pleurer monnaies comme un copeau
s'il n'a selon se voit plus qu'elle vaut
ma blonde puis les russes il c'est drôle
à dire mais
[Musique]
ils sont de plus en plus de jeunes de la
relève au pays comme jean félix à devoir
inventer un nouveau modèle d'affaires
pour posséder leur ferme et vivre de
l'agriculture
la jazzerie cette question de la gères
tu me font
d'ailleurs chez on a vu à vendre sur
facebook on n'a pas de besoin une vache
pas qu'on les a achetées au lac saint
jean
mais pour faire vivre deux familles la
jeune entreprise a besoin de nouvelles
vaches il faut acheter plus de quotas la
ferme pas d'une production laitière
d'une trentaine de kilos de matière
grasse par jour à 50 kg mais les revenus
ne sont pas encore suffisants
c'est la perspective de rentabilité
meilleure arrêtez de lait biologique
peel sale à la rejoindre nos valeurs
aussi nous la transition est assez
simple la prime accordée ou les
biologique est autour de 25% de plus que
le lait conventionnel
[Musique]
comme ils n'effectuent ni arrosage n'y
ait pendage d'engrais chimiques dans la
culture des fourrages le passage vers le
bio a été facile
et soulagement le défi de la rentabilité
est relevé pour nous les bio ce soit les
gens qu'elle reprendra demain qu'est le
6è badrou pas trop sur nos animaux
contre les sabres à zurich soit est bien
là
mais d'importants investissements
l'attendent encore de tabulation des
choses qu'on va regarder le futur
ça va dépendre des finances du marché du
lait pilotes comme un mondial mais
aujourd'hui jo félix à trente deux ans
une vingtaine d'années de moins que son
partenaire françois
oui plus jeunes mordus de boxe comme
quand j'ai fini l'école loupé mon père
nous avait plus de gaz plus d'avenir
quand un peu moins mais c'est un peu la
même chose
leur association a eu un impact sur leur
propre vie personnelle la semaine on
fait ça à nous deux nous en fin de
semaine de congé sur deux si l otan
chacun notre dame sud est et une
employée
ben l'empoli façon mieux n'est-ce pas
lui la ferme dans ce disque est un
associé bae
il fait attention c'était lui la firme
jean félix a eu la chance de réaliser
son projet de relève
grâce à sa terre acheter quand il était
étudiant aujourd'hui ils n'auraient pas
les moyens
non non non c'est sûr et certain qu'avec
le peu de mise de fond qu'on avait à
l'époque je serais incapable de racheter
la terre qu'on a acheté en 2009
l'augmentation du prix des terres est
trop fulgurant dans notre région pour
être capable de le recommencer ce que
j'ai fait
un projet de relève qui fait la sphère
des deux partenaires
petersen mais pas grossi puis là venez
l'entreprise à l'erreur pour continuer
tandis qu'un état d'urgence à perm être
construit puis qu'à une suite à
l'entreprise plus tard
[Musique]
l'établissement de jean-félix tient à la
rencontre de la bonne personne et tous
deux bénéficient de leur association
[Musique]
pour les cm2 superbe d'un an d'avril je
fais ce que j'aime je suis contente de
faire je suis parfois la sphère encore
l'antenne
[Musique]